hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be talking about the latest events in
the boku no hero manga including new
revelations about the secret intel stain
game all might intel that could be even
more important than we imagined there
was also a potentially massive death
flag for a major character in the story
and a brand new arc is about to begin so
let's get into it you guys know the
drill if you enjoy our mha videos and
you want to see more in the future just
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps with the
youtube algorithm and of course if
you're new to the channel or maybe you
watch us but you haven't taken the time
to subscribe yet do me a favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications
by the way we recently partnered with
itaikuji an online retailer in japan
that makes anime merch that is normally
exclusive to japan available to fans all
over the world they have a wide
selection of awesome anime merch
straight from japan including an entire
section on mha which has some of the
best mha figurines i've ever seen along
with a bunch of other awesome stuff
check them out the link in the
description and because we're partnered
with them you can now use the coupon
code anime opera 500 for an instant
discount every time you use the coupon
code you are not only getting awesome
merch at a discounted rate you are also
directly supporting this channel so
check them out link in the description
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hiro manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the latest chapter starts
off with a lighthearted comedic scene as
the class 1a boys literally carry deku
into the showers strip him naked wash
him and throw him into a hot bath the
way this scene is handled is honestly
kind of refreshing since the series has
been much darker lately and this is an
uncharacteristically lighthearted and
quirky moment in the story both in terms
of what's happening and in terms of how
it's actually drawn i mean i guess this
makes sense since we all know that deku
is exhausted bruised and bloodied sweaty
ragged and so on but since we've just
been reading the manga we don't have to
think about how deku actually smells
after fighting villains for like a bunch
of days straight without a break but his
classmates do have to deal with the
smell so a forced shower and bath ends
up being the best solution the one
important moment during this bath scene
is bakugo telling deku and the other
class 1a boys that he still intends to
become the number one hero and they are
still his rivals that of course includes
deku well bakugo starts to say deku but
then he changes it to izuku which is of
course very symbolic it symbolizes
bakugo's development as a character and
the development of the friendship
between bakugou and daku that said deku
doesn't really mind being called deku
and i totally agree with him there i
know the nickname deku was initially
intended to be an insult but deku
embraced it and owned it so well that
it's no longer an insult at all i mean
deku even uses the nickname as his hero
name so at this point the word has lost
all negative connotations in my mind and
i think deku feels the same way once the
class 1a students are all cleaned up
they gather in the common room where
deku thanks them and apologizes for all
the trouble that he has caused them
several of the classmates asked deku
openly about one for all and honestly
that makes sense they're all working
together now and it's better for them to
know as much about deku's quirk as
possible so that they can be as
effective as possible in battle there is
no need for deku to keep the properties
of one for all a secret from class 1a
any longer in fact if he continues to
keep it a secret it could actually
hinder their abilities to win future
battles as a team as the conversation
between the classmates continues deku
says that there is one thing that is
really bothering him and that is how he
treated all might back when they last
met as you'll recall deku told all might
that he doesn't need him anymore and he
left almighty behind in order to
continue fighting the villains on his
own worst of all he threw away that
bento box that all might had so
carefully and lovingly prepared for his
son deku but just as deku is saying all
of this shoto points out that all might
is actually right there he's creepily
looking into the window from the outside
almight then runs in and says that he is
also sorry sorry that he couldn't have
been of any help to daku i haven't
really stopped to think about this all
that much but it has to be insanely hard
for all might to be in the state that he
is currently in he is virtually helpless
to contribute to the fight against the
villains and he is severely limited in
his ability to help deku and the others
all might spent most of his life being
the strongest hero and having the power
to help everyone even in the most dire
and difficult situations and yet after
he lost the ability to use one for all
he became the exact opposite of what he
once was that is quite an adjustment for
someone to have to come to terms with
and this can't be easy for all might
that is especially the case when it
comes to deku the boy who inherited all
might squirk and whom all might mentored
for so long i mean he even made a
promise to deku's mother that he would
protect deku so not being able to do
that is a very hard pill for almight to
swallow naturally deku doesn't think
that his mentor has to apologize for
anything and all might then goes on to
reveal that he has come across some
important new information and he is
referring to the notes that stain had
left him back in the previous chapter
all might recognizes that he can't do
much on the battlefield in his current
state but he vows to keep fighting the
villains even if he has to crawl across
the battlefield to do it he is willing
to take any risk in order to nurture the
heroic flame burning in the hearts of
the class 1a students and not gonna lie
this kind of feels like a death flag
despite being extremely frail in his
current form all might is vowing to
fight even if he has to crawl on the
battlefield don't get me wrong i respect
his courage and commitment but it would
take the new shigaraki exactly half a
second to absolutely murder all might in
his current state unfortunately i can
totally see this weakened all might
sacrificing his life to save deco and
the others at some point in the future
possibly during the last major battle of
the entire series i mean all might might
survive the end of mha but if mentor
characters in other anime are any
indication almight's death is a serious
possibility anyway deku finally admits
that throwing away the bento box was
wrong and he acknowledges that the
reason he almost died was because he
left almighty side and tried to do
everything on his own as the students
agree to protect everyone together
almight smiles and heads off to meet up
with endeavour also tokoyami is totally
butthurt that his senpai hawks hasn't
been in touch with him and so he asks
omai to tell senpai to notice him the
reason why endeavor and hawks haven't
been at ua is the fact that much of the
public has lost trust in them as a
result of dobby's big revelations shoto
vows to take responsibility for
resolving the whole dobby situation and
then jiro has the brilliant idea to
bring back the band from the cultural
festival in order to help the evacuees
at the ua shelter chill out and relax a
bit the entire class vows to go beyond
and push through this difficult time
together and although i personally have
no interest in seeing another cultural
festival type arc i'm totally cool with
it if it happens off screen while we
focus on staying or maybe the villains i
know that a lot of people really liked
the cultural festival arc and that's
cool but that's definitely not the kind
of stuff i look for in a great mha arc
we then see a conversation between hawks
and genius in which hawks explains that
according to the intel that they were
able to gather from ujico they still
have about a month's time to make the
first move before shigaraki's procedure
is completed however endeavour seems to
believe that the one month timeline is
not accurate after seeing the intel
provided by stain stains notes
apparently contained the records of the
guards at tartarus and although we
aren't told what exactly the records
stated it is implied that this new
information was significant and that it
potentially changes the timeline they
had for shigaraki's full recovery the
chapter ends with endeavour
contemplating why a villain like the
hero killer stain someone he calls all
mites fanatic would actually be helping
the hero but i feel like if you know
anything about stain and his ideology
and how committed he is to that ideology
you'd know that he was always going to
pick the side of the true selfless
heroes over the villains aside from this
though i am extremely interested in that
note what do the records of the tartarus
guard say and how exactly does this
affect the timeline of shigaraki's
recovery could it be that someone at
tartarus was actually a traitor and that
they had been working with the villains
is this what stains notes prove if so
that would be a massive revelation and
it could also finally shed some light
into the now infamous ua traitor plot
point if there is a traitor at tartarus
is he or she connected to the potential
traitor at ua from this chapter it is
clear that stains intel is very
important and that it is going to have a
major effect on the story the only
question now is what exactly the intel
says and how it is going to impact the
actions of the heroes i'm getting more
and more curious about this intel with
each passing week so i hope we get some
new info soon i'm also pretty curious to
explore the inner conflict that villains
like spinner and toga might feel when
they realize that their idol stain is
now actively fighting for the heroes and
against the villains don't forget that
these guys first joined the league of
villains because they were inspired by
staying so even though they are now
loyal to the league and they feel like
the other league members are their
comrades it will be very interesting to
see their loyalties tested once they are
faced with this new villain killer stain
all in all i think that this chapter
serves as the perfect setup for a brand
new arc an arc that will probably follow
the villains for a bit before the plot
once again converges on the ua which i
think is the most likely candidate for
the final showdown in the story but let
me know what you guys think did this
chapter foreshadow almight's death in
the near future and do you think that
any major characters like all might will
eventually die in the story also what do
you think is going to happen in the next
arc since this rogue deco arc has
clearly come to an end finally how will
stains intel about the records of the
guards at tartarus affect the plot in
the future don't forget to leave your
feedback down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this boku no hero video and
you want to see more in the future you
know what to do just leave a quick like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps a lot and if you're new to
animeopro or maybe you watch our videos
but you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications quick reminder to
check out itaikuji link in the
description every product that you order
with our coupon code animeopro 500
directly supports this channel as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us peace cowboys
[Music]
you